The Joe Rogan experience. Is
there something you wrote? Yeah,
that's in high school.
Oh my God.
That you wanted to be a comedian.
It says, I want it to be,
I want to be a quantity.
I want to stand up comic and to
work with comedy on television.
Yeah. I'm willing to do whatever
it takes. Make It. Yeah.
So that says I want to do anything. I
like what I'm hearing. Whatever it takes,
whatever it takes. Look at, I wrote below.
I want you to wear a track suit with
no underwear and meet me at the doc.
Got It. We're going to get on my
yacht and you got good time. Let's go.
And I got a part for you
to read my script. Oh,
you imagine some guy takes you out on
his, on his yacht. You're like, wow.
So you really think my tape was good.
My Ah, yeah, you tape was amazing.
We're going to show them,
what do we say? Our listening,
any ae brings you this script.
It tells you what's required of you.
Yeah.
And then you're out there in the middle
of the water bobbing around staring at
this guy and he got a couple of
glasses of wine. He was like,
I'm gonna make you a star. I need to get
my dick sucked. Okay. I get that shit.
I get it. I did write in high
school anything it takes.
Now imagine being a woman
and you're in that situation.
You think you're gonna be able
to sweet talk dot guy, right?
That's why you were flirting with them
and that's why you got close to him.
You're going to get a part,
you have to play him and gonna get apart.
Next thing you know you're on that ocean.
Well that feels creepy.
That feels rapey. It is rapey. Right?
When you're a dude, you'd be like,
fuck that guy. Fucked up.
Just sacrifice, man. That's,
I'm understanding for the role that
I'm saying. It's a different feeling.
Totally right,
but still dangerous because if the guy
finds out that you're not willing and
then you might be hostile and then he
might be hostile back like your two dudes.
One Dude want to get his
dick sucked by a dude,
but they're both two dudes and it's a
real hair raising situation for both of
you. What are you paying for
him? It's hair raising, right?
You try to get this guy to suck
your Dick and the guy said,
I'll fucking kill you and you're like,
Jesus,
now I've got to drive this guy back
in my boat. It just me and him,
a guy who said he would kill me in
a 20 foot long little boat. Yeah,
you got to sit while you got to make
him set up by the bow and you just drive
quiet. What do you do? Jump in the
water. That's where people kill people.
Like you know he's going to tell people.
Yeah, totally. That's how he gets it.
That's why. That's where that
kid from Iowa goes missing.
Went to Hollywood for big dreams.
Never came back. Is that on the water?
Cement shoes my friend put on these shoes.
Yeah.
I guarantee that's happened.
But I guarantee you had guys tried to get
a guy to suck his dick and the guy who
tried to fight him and they fought
to the death. He kidding me.
I'm sure it's happening now. There's
got to, right as we're speaking,
there's got to be a nice
listening to this hallway.
Murder Jay guy is choking him to death.
He doesn't want anyone to know.
Don't go on the boat unless you really
know the guy. That's my message.
That's my message.
How well do you know the guy man or women,
if the guys that producer and he takes
you on the boats don't go on the boat.
I feel like that about, and how well do
you know the guy with the boat? Not that,
well, I'm not going on that guy's
boat. I was on a show once in,
there was a guy who was kind of a,
he was a, I don't want to be mean,
but he was sleazy.
You just Hollywood calling out
someone for being fucking sleazy.
Sleazebag but it's the, the
most stereotypical version
of, ah, yeah. And, uh,
there was a gal who is also
working on the television shown,
choose young and flirtatious
and the next thing you know,
they were on his boat for the weekend
working on the script and they came back.
We were like, wow, like you really
just said that. Yeah, we are,
we're guys creatively,
oh guys,
we're going to creatively just out in
the middle of the water and the water
gives me and Unis the water
makes me feel a type of way,
but it's like normal stuff. Like that's
what people did for US business. Yeah.
He used to be,
but Jamie wanted to bring this up because
you can sort of talking about that and
we never, oh, well this was a different
subject, but related. I'll save it.
This is a Ed buck. Do you
know who that guy is? Who?
I know he's like this democratic.
Uh, he's a a donor. Oh, right.
Oh yes. Right. And they were 10 to
two dudes had been found dead there,
um,
from drug overdoses.
So though they'd come over and one
guy said that, what did he say?
That. I don't know what
they've said, but like they,
I think what makes him do drugs or,
or he's taken them in while
they're already super high
and he's helping them out
or something. They die and they ended
up dying. Why bother? There comes,
he's claiming that he's helping
to people that think coincidence.
Maybe he's telling the truth.
Maybe he goes out there and
finds really high people.
Nice people trying to save people
in the middle of the night.
What are you cynical bro? Yeah,
Dude. What do you think is happening?
You want me to take a wild guess?
Yeah,
I bet he goes out looking for people that
are real fucked up to get back to his
apartment to get some
fucking Dick. What? No Way.
And then that side that's, and then
they say, do you have any more drugs?
And he goes,
you bet I got more fucking drugs.
They do more drugs together and they die
and he dies and he stays alive. Whoa.
You sure? Case closed, your honor. Are
you direct? I rest my second gentleman.
Mr. Buck. Okay, well it looks
like a fine man. Don't show that.
Looks like he doesn't do anything,
anything like he's got a nice gold
tooth shining in the back of his mouth.
Like a,
what's his name,
the wet bandits from home alone
investigators found multiple sex toys,
multiple syringes and clear plastic
bags with suspected suspected
methamphetamine in a toolbox
roll cabinet in the living room.
He's got a tool box fill with syringes
and sex toys. Let's go to work.
Clear plastic bags with meth more has
been homeless and how that worked out.
How it says Ma bags.
Clear plastic bags like more than many.
He's got bags of speed.
He'd been homeless and and worked
as an escort. Yeah, that's,
he was on that Gigolo show. Season Four.
He was one of the main guy. He's the guy.
I become addicted to.
Drugs in the Bush is the one to thank you.
Gave me my first
injection of crystal meth.
I become addicted to drugs and
the worst one at that. Well,
I don't know if that's true. Yeah,
but it's crazy story that the,
what we do know is true as two
people died over there. Yeah.
That's fucking insane. He's
like, hey man, just gee,
is there, there's different standards,
right? Like here's the, here's the thing,
like if that guy,
if he was a heterosexual guy and
two women had died at his house,
prison for life, what are the odds
that they wouldn't arrest him?
It zero. Zero, zero. Zero. If, if,
if one woman is found dead in
your fucking apartment. Yeah.
If you go going to go to Paris, hookers
and shoot them up with Meth, yeah,
you go to jail, you go to prison.
But if you pick up mail, okay.
It's like what we were talking about
earlier. Yeah. If it's a guy like, ah,
you're a Russian model, you came
over here to that work, Bro.
Fuck the old ladies come on. Like,
that's, it's true with these guys.
Two guys are dead and
everybody's like, Hey, you know,
that's the fucking game they're playing.
They a play in that shoot the math game.
Munch. You shoot John, you, he's
only killed two guys. What the fuck?